In the deepest darkest depths of the frigid
North Atlantic Ocean lies a 1.2 square kilometre
island called Hans Island and Canada and Denmark
just can't help but put their sticky "Hans"
all over it.
Hans Island lies directly in the middle of
Nares Strait, which separates Canada from
Greenland, Greenland as you may know is an
overseas territory owned by Denmark.
Since 1930 there has been an ongoing dispute
between the Canadian and Danish governments
over who owns this small, barren island in
the middle of absolutely nowhere.
You see, under international law, which is
just fancy terminology for The Pirate's Code,
all countries have the right to claim any
land within 12 miles of their coastline.
Since the Nares Strait, which Hans Island
sits in, is only 22 miles wide, that puts
the island within 12 miles of both Greenland
and Canada, meaning they both have a claim
to it.
So, who actually owns it?
Well, I'm sorry Canada, but the island was
officially ruled to be Danish territory by
the Permanent Court of International Justice
of the League of Nations in 1933.
However, shortly afterwards the League of
Nations was abolished, which made them really
regret calling it the Permanent Court.
It was replaced with the United Nations.
After which Denmark's claim to Hans Island
was kind of forgotten by every other nation,
since it no longer carried any weight.
Canada subsequently told Denmark to keep their
"Hans" off Hans Island and the two have been
bickering about it ever since.
Luckily Canada and Denmark are fairly peaceful
nations and this long running dispute is often
settled in a humorous manner.
In 1984 Denmark's minister of Greenland affairs
visited Hans Island and stuck a Danish flag
in it.
At the base of the flag he left a note that
read "Welcome to the Danish Island", he also
left a bottle of brandy.
This marked the start of the so-called "whiskey
war" between the two nations.
Ever since that day, the two nations' militaries
have been randomly sailing to Hans Island,
replacing the other nation's flag with their
own and leaving a bottle of whiskey and a
sign saying either "Welcome to Canada" or
"Welcome to Denmark".
Danish ambassador Peter Jensen said that whenever
the Danish visit the island they leave a bottle
of Schnapps and the Canadians apparently leave
a bottle of Canadian Club whiskey.
It's like the coldest cold-war that ever happened.
This may all seem a bit silly for two countries
arguing over land, but to me it seems a lot
more mature than nuclear warheads, and certainly
a lot funnier too.
But even Canada and Denmark recognise that
it may not be all Schnapps and giggles forever.
The two nations see it as a friendly but long-standing
dispute and they both admit it has potential
to cause friction in the future, especially
since melting ice caps makes the arctic circle
an ever increasingly attractive place for
trade routes between certain countries.
So, there are currently plans to turn Hans
island into a condominum, which would mean
it is collectively owned by both countries,
so basically they have to share and no more
whiskey or sarcastic signs.